foreign
wow uh thank you guys uh I just want to
thank God you know first and foremost uh
because you know I wouldn't have been
here without without him and uh
obviously my teammates have been a big
part of it
and obviously you I wouldn't be standing
here you know if you haven't been
winning and you know obviously like I
said these guys that did everything
possible for me to be in this situation
and obviously my parents uh
my family has been a big part of it
obviously we went through such a you
know huge tragedy losing my little
brother but you know we stuck together
uh you know we went through a lot and uh
you know my family uh my son is
somewhere over there
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you know he gave me this opportunity to
come to the U.S and I'm here
and then you guys
oh man we went through a lot you know
all these years the walk is not done we
gonna need you guys you know all your
support for the rest of you know this
playoffs we got along with the girls so
you know thank you guys and you know
keep supporting us and let's get it
let's get it started